[Musik]
es ist heute
aber nicht nur für dich selbst für mich
ist es kalt
jagdszenen aus sand gang der
nigerianische drucken polizist alle jene
jones nach bola ist unterwegs mit st
galler polizisten auf der suche nach
nigerianischen drogenhändlern
man sieht hier ist niemand
noch vor kurzem waren sie überall
bekommen nun jeden tag hierher und sie
zu kontrollieren man kann das sehen
schon sehr bald wird es keine drogen
geben in den straßen von st an
[Musik]
drogen polizist adeyemi abholer wald für
drei wochen in st gallen die schweiz hat
mit nigeria eine zusammenarbeit im kampf
gegen den straßen handel mit kokain
vereinbart denn dieser ist in einigen
schweizer städten in den händen von
nigerianern und so geraten in st gallen
in diesen tagen afrikaner ins visier
eines anderen afrikaners
es ist ein süchtiger ein eritrea mit
aufenthaltsbewilligung
weißt du was weil du drogen nimmst
kriegst du keinen job du hast nämlich
überhaupt keine kraft zu arbeiten
glaubst du mir
ich glaube es
doch hier in der schweiz haben sie zu
viel geld und zu viel stress
hörst du s sowie geld und
zu viel stress also um den stress zu
unterdrücken nimmst du drogen
empfiehlt ein job deshalb muss man ihn
beschäftigen denn nach der arbeit der
müde seinen schlafengehen statt drogen
zu nehmen stimmt
beim bahnhof haben die polizisten zwei
verdächtige erblickt
[Musik]
ich habe gesehen wie einer von ihnen
hier etwas weggeworfen hat
es stellt sich dann heraus die zwei
nigerianer leben in einem
asylbewerberheim weit weg in biel sie
sind vor zwei monaten aus italien in die
schweiz gekommen auf der suche nach
arbeit
ich bin zur schweizer
einwanderungsbehörde gegangen und habe
gesagt bitte gebt mir arbeit ich handle
nicht mit drogen und
was machen sie hier
[Musik]
ich kam um eine frau zu treffen
haben sie etwas verbotenes in ihren
taschen drogen waffen solche dinge
sicher
haben sie etwas in ihrem mund können sie
ihn öffnen zu mir nach oben
du bist ein verdächtiger du hast keinen
job du hast keinen grund hier zu sein
die sache ist wir wollen keine
drogenhändler mehr im st
wenn du eine von diesen bisher zurück
nach italien verstehst du
ich bin keine von diesen
als nigerianer habe ich genug von all
den scheußlichkeiten die von landsleuten
hier begangen werden deshalb bin ich
hier wir wollen nicht dass ihr das
ansehen nigerias weiter beschädigt
er ist fast jeder niger jahren ein
verdächtiger wir in der aktivitäten
einiger weniger dieser ort ist nicht
mehr länger ein ort für drogenhändler es
ist ein sehr heißer ort und ich mache
ihn dazu es ist besser zu gehen
du kannst die nigeria besser leben hat
hier auf der straße wurde von polizisten
gejagt wird denn wenn du hier keine
arbeit hast ist die versuchung groß
kriminell zu werden
ein missionarischer eifer treibt adeyemi
abholer bei seinem schweizer einsatz an
denn der drogenhandel hier verursacht
schäden auch zu hause
wenn drogenhändler nach nigeria zurück
kehren zeigen sie ihr geld und da
startet dann die jungen an
sie wollen wissen hey wie hast du dieses
viele geld gemacht in europa europa ist
toll hören sie dann dort liegt das geld
auf der straße
jungen werden getäuscht viele von ihnen
haben nichts gelernt und keinen beruf
sie suchen arbeit ihnen wird der
eindruck vermittelt in europa sei alles
gut hier kann man leicht geld machen
verstehst du
in der hochblüte des textilgeschäfts
gehörte samt können zu den reichsten
dynamischsten städten der welt
mittlerweile hat die ostschweizer stadt
zu einer selbstgenügsamen
beschaulichkeit gefunden die so gar
nicht zu einem drogenhandels platz
passen will
eine drogensüchtige wird sagt karla und
umgebung kennt ja bis der zug und die
ich dass es nach russland deutschland
und österreich konsument ebenfalls die
schweiz kommen im fotodruck beziehen
will in österreich und deutschland star
ist schwierig zumal betäubungsmittel an
mir oft vor allem für österreich
konsumenten mit dem auto oder fahrrad
heroin kokain beziehen das druck bringen
oestrich das ist der grund warum
minister handeln für mittelgroße stadt
relativ groß florian
tatsächlich sahen sich die st galler
behörden im jahre 2011 veranlasst gegen
600 nigerianer eine wegweisung zu
verfügen aufgrund des verdachts von
drogenhandel eine eindrückliche zahlen
die staatsanwaltschaft liefert eine
einschätzung dazu
ich sehe natürlich schaut aus dräger
sahen vor denen nigeria anderer
beherrscht wird das ist offensichtlich
aber der muss fs serie oder die lütze im
verhältnis sehr wenige oder also es gibt
wahrscheinlich dass staatsfunk essbar
schweizer drogendealer wo geholfen wo
erheblich mehr umsatz machen aus die
runden
im regen unterwegs ist
durch diese 100 nigerianer sind eben
viel augenfälliger in stadtbild außer
gerade runter denn der polizeieinsatz
scheint sich herumgesprochen zu haben
was einen aufwendigeren körpereinsatz
erfordert
und selbst dann ist der erfolg nicht
sicher
ja sie müssen davon ist doch bessere uns
bei der nächsten begegnung zeigt sich
wie verschlungen die weltweite wanderung
sein kann
dieser mann wohnt angeblich in paris
stammt aus der elfenbeinküste hat aber
einen nigerianischen pass was der
nigerianischen polizisten sehr skeptisch
macht und eine rückfrage im
polizeicomputer steigert die
ratlosigkeit noch
[Musik]
unsere recherche ergab dass eine person
mit diesem namen als asylbewerber in
burgdorf lebt stimmt das ja das war vor
jahren damals war der mann in der
schweiz der liebe wegen sagt er doch nun
lebt er in paris wo er auf irgendwelchen
wegen zu diesem nigerianischen pass kam
und so wird gewinnen um die wahrheit die
französisch englisch und ihr rüber
ich habe keine drogen und ich bin kein
band
in der schweiz haben wir keine probleme
mit ihm es ist also okay für uns
verständigen
sie sind viel höflichkeit michael
kontrolle macht wenn er nötig sind sie
sehr arrogant rennen sehr aufbrausend
sei ein versuch aufmerksamkeit für die
luft um sich um sich damit mehr als in
ruhe lernen und wenn ja dann bin ich
merkt man sofort dass sie ganz ruhig
sind und sehr anständig und da dachte
ich glaube extrem
adeyemi abdullah studierte psychologe
verhör spezialist vater von vier kindern
zum ersten mal ist er im ausland und zum
ersten mal im schnee was ihn am
wochenende dazu bewogen hat er
sicherheitshalber den ganzen tag auf
seinem zimmer zu bleiben
es war extrem kalt nach dem frühstück
war nicht den ganzen tag nicht mein
zimmer zu verlassen
ich hatte wieder ein mittagessen noch
ein nachtessen und ging am samstagabend
hungrig zu bett es war keine angenehme
erfahrung
die fahrt nach bern führt zur
bundespolizei fedpol
dort trifft der emi abholer zwei
kollegen welche in zürich dienst tun
afrikaner mit kurzen hemden im schnee
2011 kamen die ersten offiziere der
nigerianischen drogenpolizei nba in die
schweiz
die nigerianer erhoffen sich durch diese
zusammenarbeit die illegalen drogen
geldflüsse aus der schweiz in irland
unterbinden zu können
und eine motivation in die kalte schweiz
zu reisen liegt gewiss auch in den 2500
franken die jeder ndr polizist für die
drei wochen erhält
scharfschützen ja alle
das ist großartig ich bin beeindruckt
die kerle sein begnadetes scharfschützen
alle von euch und
dann darf auch an der chemie abholer
zeigen dass er ein kerl ist das muss er
ja auch sein denn sein job in nigeria
ist lebensgefährlich als er vor drei
jahren eine operation gegen
drogenhändler leitete wurden zwei seiner
kollegen erschossen
vor santala stadtpolizisten hält der
nigerianer einen vortrag schildert wie
am flughafen von lagos gegen
drogenschmuggler vorgegangen wird das
auch anderenorts auf der welt an
flughäfen nach drogen gesucht wird hat
er auf seinem flug von lagos in die
schweiz selber erfahren müssen beim
umsteigen in frankfurt geriet er der
nigerianer wie selbstverständlich zu
verdächtigen personen und
frankfurter dena kalt geworden und sie
hinten alles das was genau kommt und zu
herzen
wenn ich dann noch als er geht es dem
grunde flug verpasst
hatte chemie abdullah schildert auch wie
an petrotec security agency
unpatriotisch iranische sicherheitsleute
sich von drogenschmugglern bestechen
lassen
unpatriotisch mal hier korrupt nigeria
mitsamt seiner polizei geht als eines
der korruptesten länder der welt
und so wagt ein zuhörer die frage zu
stellen die wohl auch alle anderen
anwesenden beschäftigt wie ist das mit
der korruption bei der nigerianischen
drogenpolizei mdl
glaub mir ich bin stolz dir sagen zu
können dass es in der nba keine
korruption gibt ich bin nicht ich
arbeite seit fast 20 jahren in diesem
job und habe immer noch kein eigenes
haus und
[Applaus]
dann ist wieder jagdzeit in den kalten
straßen von st der afrikaner der
angehalten wird hat eine
aufenthaltsbewilligung lebt seit sieben
jahren in der schweiz kein fall für die
drogenfahnder
was machst du
ich arbeite
arbeite ist das ist gut bezahlte arbeit
das ist gut er ist ein guter mann der
seine arbeit nicht zu tun mit drogen
[Musik]
dieser nigerianische asylbewerber ist
vier stunden von zion hierher gefahren
um wie er sagt einen freund zu besuchen
von dem er weder den namen die adresse
noch eine telefonnummer nennen kann
der mann hat nach beobachtungen der
polizisten etwas geschluckt womöglich
kokainkügelchen bevor er angehalten
worden war
polizist mark holenstein wohl
telefonisch informationen ein diese
ergeben dass der mann bereits in bern
wegen drogenhandels vermerkt ist ja sie
haben mich mit einem tödlichen kokain
erwischt und mir gesagt dass ich mich
deshalb von bern fernhalten soll
aber sie verboten ist in ihren taschen
waffen
doch wie fast immer bei solchen
kontrollen drogen finden die polizisten
keine
wir haben die nase voll wir haben genug
davon dass leute wie du damit so dass
leute wie du das ansehen von nigeria
beschädigen
nigeria ist ein guter ort zum leben wir
können ihn noch besser machen wenn wir
sein ansehen nicht zerstören ausländer
wagen kaum mehr geschäfte mit nigeria zu
machen in der kriminalität einiger
weniger
wenn du aufhören würdest drogen zu
verkaufen hätte die jugend in der
schweiz ihren frieden du ebenfalls in
nigeria könnte stolz sein hier könnte
ich ohne uniform nicht durch diese stadt
gehen ohne von polizisten gestoppt zu
werden nur weil ich schwarz bin
weil einige wenige das ansehen nigerias
beschädigt haben
diese gesetze die solar
hast du das in nigeria tun könntest du
sie nigeria auch nur eine so kleine
menge kokain verkaufen und immer noch
frei herumlaufenden du weißt das ist
unmöglich
er ist in gera auch wie gesetzt trifft
auf die einzige kann im bistro und auf
die andere gesetze nicht durchsetzen ist
dass nigeria macht wie man jede welt ist
gefängnis stecken für 22 jahre wo
marihuana raucht oder das bild so die
kokain auf 63 dann hätte man glatt zu
wenig verhängnis und er kaufte er bereit
ist unendlich gestiegen im polizeiarrest
untersuchen die polizisten die sachen
eines nigerianers der auf der straße
angehalten worden ist der verdacht der
mann könnte kokain aus spanien geliefert
haben
stell ich da hin
schau mich an
ich bin ein nigerianer wie du ich bin
offiziell ea
der mann ist asylbewerber in spanien
hält sich illegal in der schweiz auf und
wohnt seit drei wochen angeblich in
einem zürcher hotel dessen namen er aber
nicht nennen kann er sagt er sei
geschäftsmann und habe autos gekauft in
der schweiz
so erwähnt dass du auto gekauft hast da
sind keine dokumente etwas zeigen wenn
du tatsächlich autos gekauft hast dann
müssten doch die quittungen warten sein
er konnte mich nicht überzeugen davon
dass er nach sand garten gekommen ist um
legale geschäfte zu tätigen
doch beweise für eine straftat gibt es
nicht der mann wird nach dieser
befragung freigelassen und muss die
schweiz innert zwei tagen verlassen
schwache gesetze findet der chemie labor
in nigeria könnte er den mann tagelang
ohne richterbeschluss festhalten und
weich klopfen
heute hat der nigerianische drogen
polizist einen termin beim ersten
staatsanwalt des kantons st gallen
bei staatsanwalt thomas hansjakob sitz
der nigerianer praxis vor der richtigen
amtsperson um seine verwunderung
auszudrücken über die wie er findet
weichen gesetze gegen das drogengeschäft
an dass bei uns wo die gesetze hart
genug sind
wenn du in nigeria wegen kokain oder
heroin handel verhaftet ist dann wirst
du entsprechend bestraft
20 jahre gefängnis und wir glauben dies
ist abschreckend genug nach 20 jahren im
gefängnis kommst du als guter nigerianer
wieder raus
[Musik]
ich verstehe was sie meinen der
unterschied liegt darin dass die strafe
in der schweiz generell weniger hart
sind als in nigeria nicht nur gegen
drogenhandels
das hat damit zu tun dass die menschen
in der schweiz viel mehr zu verlieren
haben als
im laden zum abschied klingt auch
resignation mit dieses land mit seinem
freundlichen gesetzen ist im afrikaner
zum heizen geworden
sie steht gegenüber der schweizer
funktioniert wenn sie es gegenüber der
nigerianer vielleicht weniger gut
funktioniert benedikt das müssen sich
auf neue würden wir können die
sonderrecht für andere
nationalitäten weniger funktioniert
heißt so zu wenig abschrecken das ist
was ich nach wicker so dass die leute
das was sie hier erwartet ein
strafverfahren
zu wenig abgeschreckt werden das hätte
aber möglicherweise nicht nur mit der
strafe sondern mit dem verfahren an sich
zu ihr und natürlich dass es zu und es
absurd wenn man sich wieder abbas seien
also den müssten rettungskurs zur
nationalität der fotos ist auch dass der
helm quält sie es sind an der chemie
abholer stats der tage in st gallen wo
die innenstadt als rotes kunstwerk
gestaltet ist eine schöne reiche stadt
in einem schönen reichen land und in
dieser pracht möchte der nigerianer
erklären warum diese vielen jungen
männer aus seiner heimat hierher reisen
die mehrheit dieser jungen männer ist
arm sie stammen aus armen familien in
nigeria diese männer sind nach europa
gekommen um im drogengeschäft tätig zu
werden sie ist die situation hier ohne
arbeit die sie dazu brachte mit drogen
zu handeln deshalb bin ich hier meinen
neuen landsleuten zu sagen sie sollen
nach hause zurückkehren hamann l zu
werden